[Music]
welcome
back to it's not off the record okay it
is
ask the expert and i know you guys love
this series i personally do because you
get a different side of
all of us and we get to focus on experts
instead of us being a bunch of dudes
guessing and shooting
in the [ __ ] dark yeah making
[ __ ] up and then pretending like we know
what we do
but i know everything i'm happy to
introduce our guests for today we have
andrew chao from boba guys our biggest
competitor
i wanted him to come on our show so we
could steal all of his ideas because
we're going to be
thank you very much i don't know how you
got convinced me to drink this baby turn
the cup around get that logo in there
there you go there you go look at that
make a meme out of this yeah it's like
mcdonald's and carl's jr we got the ceo
to oh
dude that's getting like steve jobs to
hold up android yeah [ __ ] yeah it's like
and smile that's true but no um
i i actually do look up to andrew a lot
because
i think you know in the space of dessert
drinks boba and all that
you guys revolutionized in my opinion
um boba in a way where i thought it was
already saturated and i thought it was a
place where it was like
you can't no more players can come into
the game and
i don't know if this was your intention
or not but i saw boba guys as
the bridge between mainstream america
and boba
and these asian dessert drinks so i was
like that's pretty amazing and i think
with junebe too like what we try to do
is we want to you know provide high
quality matcha at an accessible rate to
the mainstream american public or just
the world you know we're going to go a
little bit further than you guys but
like
you know uh but yeah so how did you get
started in all this
and how many stores you have yeah how
many stores you have right
right now 300 uh no not even close uh
i we're we think we're down to like uh
we we shut down new york for a bit but
then uh
16 i think if i counted 16 of them and
we were supposed to 20 in 2020
that was kind of a whole thing but then
uh we'll be by the end of the year i
think back up to 20.
but i think um so so you had how many
i had 17 and in one okay kovid
literally i was in the middle of three
and that it was like the worst time for
covet to hit
because i'm sure you guys know you're
shelling out cash to
get ready to open a store but that's you
need it back but in the middle of a
build-out i had to
spend money to finish a store only to
not really make money during the
pandemic
so and you told me you were just you're
about to open five here in southern
california
all right dude you got an exclusive
already oh is that a secret am i
supposed to not say that five five total
but part of it is catching up to the
three that we kind of lost
so we had kind of the cash that we had
to like absorb we lost money last year
but we
uh although apple's not fair fight with
with with microsoft
no i'm dominated um but no we are
building
we're building stores which we'll talk a
little bit about you know people think
it's oh oh
they must be rolling in cash and all
that kind of stuff no there's a lot of
other economics that come into play
where
sadly part of the reason you can build a
little faster out of a pandemic i'm sure
people can figure out is there's a lot
of open vacancies yeah so it's just
cheaper to build out
and more people need work because few
people are opening so
the prices of labor goes down for build
outs a little bit yeah
yeah i think um we had a you know we
were able to franchise and get
everything ready
by early 2020 but then as the pandemic
hit
a lot of the people that were ready to
sign up with us
were like uh we're just gonna wait this
one out and we only had you know
two brave entrepreneurs that decided to
keep going
and um yeah so we were able to open one
in new jersey and we're gonna open up
three in texas
i saw where in jersey's i'm from
princeton oh okay that's further i'm
from
woodbridge which is like okay like
princeton's a little bit like
yeah it's a little further down but um
wait so you're not from north cal no
people i am from norcal but most of my
energy people are like oh you talk like
like super
i'm from jersey i would say my mental
energy is like italian
jewish that's why if you see people like
oh andrew like doesn't act like a normal
asian like all the stuff that's going on
right now right they're like
oh that that energy is like that's kind
of aggressive i'm like
yeah because when i was a kid i was the
only asian kid in town
my parents ran the restaurant on main
street when you see people do you just
like grab your nuts and shake it up
do you want a piece of this hey yeah get
the [ __ ] out of here
yeah so it was next to see and that's
why he's so successful because he's an
east coast workaholic right
well that's i am a workaholic and yeah
it's a working-class kind of
jersey the whole the whole state is a
very kind of blue-collar state so yeah
a lot of asians there though i didn't
yes yeah it's cool like how many asians
can i ask what makes you go like you're
like you put on a piece of paper
say it's ten years ago and you're like
i'm gonna do a boba shop what's
step one for that and how do you take
that and turn it into 14
uh locations 16 16.
um one's 20. at the end of this year
21. um no what 20 is the number where
you start
hitting into different legal issues they
call it uh really
yeah you run into like uh formula retail
a lot of cities
where you have to go through extra hoops
because you're too big
which is good actually in a different
category now yeah they're gonna i'm
gonna be in the
19 is our starbucks no that's what
people aim like 19. you guys have a lot
of cool brands you guys are smarter
right so you guys
build your 19 brands of all of them so
you never really hit 19 of one
19 of one hat store sock store underwear
store you could do that
actually you could probably pull that
off just buy all these complexes with
all these kiosks
um yeah so how did you get started so we
got started
true i mean i'm not this is first of all
i'm not just flying
i've obviously i know you guys a little
bit offline but
online a lot of it i started in 2011
right
but that was also when you guys were
popping off with and people know we're
close with you know
phil wong fu um and he's got his
mofo shots to him although we're not
gonna drink him on camera
um so when you guys started i was
watching
you know asian youtubers right and some
of you guys people know boba guys knows
a lot of
the crew is because a lot i was a party
promoter uh
so i had like hired like uh our group
had hired you know
you know early day fm farce movement
stuff
so there was always this kind of like
hey there might be cultural play right
i was in i was it's gonna sound super
booster or leaders but i grew up
i'll talk about later i didn't grow up
with a lot of money but i didn't go to
business school
and now when i was in business school i
was in shanghai during this like
trek or business school trek i was there
for a month and i was looking down in
this area called shintandi which is uh
it's like the expat area my uncle lives
there he's a big vc
and i remember seeing a haagen-dazs and
haagen-dazs was like super blown up
and i was like i told my uncle michael i
was like hey
i didn't know ice cream did so well in
china like it i hadn't gone as
does everyone get diarrhea from it yeah
exactly right it's like
i don't want to overly stereotype but
like do you guys have different you know
jeans or than us back at home but then
you go no no it's big and you know
american stuff is really big here i'm
sure you know this and i said yeah and
he goes you know what
he's like he calls me did i die he was
like andrew like little kid andrew
you're this marketing guy because before
business school i was in marketing
uh well i still did it a little bit
afterwards but it's like how come you
don't
build a really good brand and how come
you don't make a people proud of asians
such an asian like elder girl he's just
straight up yo
how come you suck at the [ __ ] that you
studied it exactly
no good huh i have a good question
he came to my grand opening swear to god
he told my mom oh i don't even tell the
story
he's at the not to be like we have a
book out he the last chapter is actually
about him
true story he actually even told my mom
how come andrew doesn't dream bigger
swear to god wow i was like oh my god
where is he
at where he can say this is he like
baller you baller or is he just like
he's
broke as [ __ ] just talking [ __ ] he's
still ashamed of you he's a
big he's he's slightly less ashamed now
but uh
my uncle you know he's a self-made man
he's a big venture capital
people might if i didn't say i don't
want to say so his standards are like
why don't you chase up 300 stores
why are you doing 16 yeah well yeah
because he
can't he came to my grand opening
actually i remember sitting in the
corner and i was in the back making
drinks and he was just upset
no he was he's a pile of cigarettes this
high and he's smoking
he was really proud oh no yeah he was
like
he he was part of like i don't know if
you guys feel this
people think oh it's your asian parents
but there's other relatives that you
fight for their approval
right right and there's it's crazy
because like whole
army and a lot of other ethnicities it
doesn't really matter besides your
parents but then in ours it's like
there's a whole like board of advisors
you need
exactly everyone's got a thing to say
man and it's like shut the [ __ ] up
but then they help you in so many ways
seriously you gotta shut the [ __ ] up and
just
make them happy yeah so basically it was
about culture it was about like
all right can we make people proud
because i was watching like you guys
and i was like for the first time
because before that the only time i saw
like cultural coolness i mean before
fresh off the boat so
there wasn't really any maybe i saw lucy
lewin kill bill which was
exoticized right so yeah so you saw them
doing wig comedy and you're like wow
this is making me proud
now you guys were making like films and
it was uh you know all the dancers were
making cool stuff that's why i respect
you know a lot of the
you know like i went to i was at norcal
so a lot of the dancers that we saw to
go on
you guys know i mean we're talking to
people before this is like uh
you know abdc so that was getting hot so
what i was like could
that happen for uh food
and bauhaus had just started taking off
that's eddie right and people know like
i love eddie eddie's like my big bro my
dagger
eddie huang and then david chang had not
yet popped off
so it's really just eddie but he was
kind of like leading the way
and then so what happened was where i'm
also then lived in the bay area
phil's coffee and blue bottle came out
of the bay area
and so we were like what if we took the
culture of kind of what we do
with the model of blue bottle blue
bottle was really if you look at boba
guys
it's who i probably emulate the most
what's their
what's their model they're kind of like
quantico artisanal
bougie third wave right so that means
like everything is a little bit more
handcrafted
higher quality kind of global mindset
i mean blue bottle should give a little
bit more credit to where they kind of
took the ideas from their their japanese
coffee style right you know this yeah
i mean you you you and i love tea and
matching cafes and stuff and like
if you go to asia most of the hottest
concepts now are basically
asia concepts that people re-skin in
america because
asia has already because it's cheaper to
build out and they kind of are a little
bit more global than we are in america
they're always watching what happens in
europe but what happens in in middle
east and what happens in
america so these cafes like the japanese
like
most of these equipment things that we
see for coffee like hario
these slow drip it was invented that was
there for like 50 60 years
because our our coffee culture in
america evolved differently
from like australia asia and europe and
like
because i think in america the great
depression changed
how they consumed coffee it was more
like
more bang for your buck get yourself a
huge can of coffee for like 50 cents and
you get more
drink right giant folgers yeah so that's
i don't know if that's considered first
wave but that was
the coffee culture i see yeah that was
like that was the longest and then
starbucks kind of changed the game
because it's like you go to the coffee
shop
and then you know and then you have the
pete's coffee and everybody else that
was that custom adjustments or whatever
yeah and then third wave or whatever is
the more in between
but then you have your specialty
roasters and whatever too that's
is that even fourth wave i don't know
let's help but let's tell people who are
watching this who don't even know what
you're talking about third wave fourth
wave fifth wave like
we got what i was trying to explain it's
fine but i'm saying like when it comes
to like you have an idea for a business
and now you're gonna make that alive
you're gonna take that from a piece of
paper or whatever you had and you're
going to actually bring it into
existence like what's your first step or
how does that work
first step is what model do you want to
go after it's what i generally say
like you know a bunch of us probably
mentor all their businesses what i tell
mentees i almost always say
what do you want like what's your
closest emulation you're like i want to
be my own person it's like i don't know
if people want to be an actor i'm like
am i going to be hugh jackman or am i
going to be like matt damon or
hopefully not white might guys but like
what what sorry
but what um like what's your what's your
goal
so for me it was blue bottle so i was
aiming for a blue bottle
model meaning i don't need crazy volumes
like
like quickly or these like big boba
shops i was not going to be
overtly kind of like like like a
pretentious
specialty brand yeah yeah yeah like
third wave roasting
single origin you know blue bottle was
roughly accessible because they were in
kind of like
just upper middle class kind of uh like
sweet greens
for first salads so when we were putting
that idea together
it was like could we do it the number
one thing was
it doesn't exist but why doesn't exist
and i think that's the real question
like if you're going into a territory
where it's never really been done before
or never been popularized it's usually
one of two reasons one is because
somebody's tried it and everybody kept
on failing or
no one's kind of cracked the nut of the
problem so that's where
my marketing background comes in where
you know this is where i don't really
this is a great forum because you guys
are like
fun and i can talk about my nerdy stuff
but to be honest like
a true marketing anybody who's the
marketing you fundamentally believe
the future's wide open because a
marketer's job is to create demand
out of nowhere and so i was like could
high-end boba come out and so some
people said
well if it if it was available or
somebody would have done it already
boba's been around for 30 years at the
time on the other hand people are like
well
how you gonna do it how are you gonna
convince people to like boba when you
know like
americans don't even try anything
different
so to me i'm like well what if that's a
marketing problem so
in the first year we did a pop-up and we
really
you know did it in a way that was like
making both asians feel proud
me meaning like it was cool boba
it's why we kind of started with kind of
the hype kind of kind of hypebeast world
and then with um with a little bit of
americans saying hey if you don't know
what boba is and you didn't grow up in
san gabriel valley cupertino or these
kind of enclaves
boba can still be for you because that
the real honest question was
i used to i used to work in corporate
right so i'd go my and i used to work at
clorox which is in oakland
and there's a chinatown next to the
headquarters and we'd go out for coffee
it's what you do when you were you're
yappy right sorry i'm not to say this on
a different youtube channel
okay so is that wongfu's word yeah
is that no is it who created that word i
don't know you're the one who has to
stand by it
yeah exactly so the
uh some asian professional uh with my
colleagues would go to for coffee down
the street in oakland but
i remember this i'd go to a boba shop
which was next to
the headquarters and they would always
go to like modern coffee or starbucks
which is these
coffee places that are next to each
other in the plaza and
we'd go back to our office and go back
to our desks but i'd had boba and
sometimes i'd bring them to a meeting
and i would then invite my co-workers
who generally were not
asian and they just i could tell you
just
you could just read on their face they
couldn't feel comfortable so now you
have a choice one hand
it's like you shove it down your throat
and be like what you're so ignorant
you're so naive
yeah like how come you don't you're just
you don't want to try new things
i can tell you that doesn't work no you
know
i was like you know make it more
accessible so what i
had always done is sometimes i even like
like milk tea for like friends and stuff
like that so
and i came out oh i came out of the food
business so on top of that
i grew up in a restaurant in new jersey
so my
my dad opened a restaurant in woodbridge
so i had already had a food background i
was always very comfortable around food
and getting dirty i don't mind like
cleaning up [ __ ] and
stuff like that so that combined was
like all right
could then there be a missing kind of
there's a huge hole
the reason hasn't been cracked was a
marketer couldn't
figure out the story and that's where i
looked at you guys i
i looked at you know what i when i saw
between you know the big youtubers
especially
some of you guys crossed over a little
bit crossed over quote unquote like
into not just asian youtube yeah
differently you guys were one of them
because i looked at your you guys's
you know you know sometimes it was super
asian other days i would watch and i'd
be like oh my gosh it's all it's asians
run but a bunch of other people who
aren't just asian
that to me was kind of how i felt like
that model can work so we just chose
blue bottle and tacked it on with kind
of the asian culture so you knew you
were gonna do boba is that something
that you chose
and you created and then afterwards
you're like aha i'm gonna be like blue
bottle
and then make it more accessible and and
change it
like did you have the store first and
then evolve or did you think of all this
first and then create make the
good question i would say chicken in the
egg it's a little bit of both we
essentially did a pop-up and the pop-up
was called boba guy so we knew
we were gonna do boba from the pop-up
but we were exploring this is where it's
like a little bit i don't know what came
first
yeah how it really happened was my
co-founder and i don't drink much
like alcohol yeah you know we had the
asian flush which is a separate thing
and then so we were at a company when we
met
called timbuktu do you guys know
timbuktu yeah yeah
so it's uh i i don't mean this in any
way it was just an outdoor-ish
hipster company so it was like pretty
white yeah so
even when i went to coffee breaks back
then and or
timbuktu had like kegs on tap all the
time you know because it's like
outdoors they always got tap and
everybody bikes and has their pen ears
on their
their bicycles so we were like
we don't want to drink beer with them so
we'd go grab boba and so
when we go grab boba and set up beer and
bring it back to the happy hour
like we knew we maybe thought we were
gonna do apparel
like a spin-off off of uh timbuktu
because we both you know been
my co-founder is like super fashionable
he's like close with you know erelson
from acronym and
that's where the hypebeast kind of stuff
comes from it comes from him and then
we were drinking boba every time we
brainstormed though so probably for a
three month period
we were thinking about what fashion and
accessory which brands we want to make
like straps for like cameras which at
the time
everybody's shooting dslrs so we thought
we're going to do that our friend rich
actually started a company that became
it which was dispatch
if you guys know dispatch he actually
became the company that uh
out of san francisco that actually was
the idea that bin and i wanted to do
oh we saw we had a different friend
start it yeah
and then you guys went to boba guys yeah
and you got food
like you were gonna do merch like i mean
clothes yeah well you come from your
pop-up shop and then you're like i want
to do merch now maybe
so while we were like thinking of these
ideas
every time i was drinking boba while
everybody else was drinking beer
everybody's like
what is you know san francisco what's
the best idea what are we gonna what's
the next startup
so every one day was just like what
about this
and that's when it started the seed of
the idea 2010.
i thought about it for a year we're like
what if it was food and beverage not
apparel but food and beverage
and that's when by the time we knew we
wanted bob guys it was just a matter of
how we're going to execute
like do you go full in store first which
is a whole separate strategy or a pop-up
we did pop-up because little did we we
got lucky
the most famous pop-up probably ever is
mission chinese
which is danny boeing he was a street
down from our original pop-up
so it was all in the mission district in
san francisco
so we literally didn't know what pop-ups
were when we started the idea
but by the time we had the full baked
idea we were like why don't we do it the
mission chinese style where we go into
another place so there was a japanese
ramen restaurant that our friend ran
and that was how we started boba guys
wow the japanese restaurant
mm-hmm steph stefan and um stefan and
robert
they were they had no business actually
letting us there
they just um they just believed in us
honestly
there's stories where i'm sure you guys
had this how do you get your start
there's always those people they just
give you a chance yeah
so that lady gaga thing there's 99
people in the room and or what just
takes one person
it was them because nobody else was
willing to put if somebody dies from
your drink or chokes or whatever that's
the insurance is on the restaurant yeah
not on the pop-up
so they were and we dealt with hot water
i mean this is a story i never really
got to tell ever we didn't we didn't
know how much tea we're going through
so we were running out of hot water
constantly in the early days
and we were we didn't we we launched
pretty hot first day we sold 200 right
out of the bat what what made you what
do you think
like help with that success i think we
should most people like you when you
start like a brand new
like a brand new brand there's like for
example me and my wife first started bar
brigade
we went to uh the california state
powerlifting
championships i think in like 2013
and coming from like the youtube world
we're already pretty big from jk
i'm used to like 100 200 500 000 people
in the auditorium i'm like cool we're
gonna [ __ ] clear this [ __ ]
so we go there we set up our little uh
our little wwf table
and we sold two shirts that day one
because some
some person came and just liked skull
and crossbones and they'll get skull and
crossbones anything
and the other one was nadim who was
lifting that day and he was actually a
fan
and that's it and then we're like [ __ ] i
don't think
this is gonna work out i'll be looking
to you guys now tumbling though that's
humbling it is humbling but it's
but it's like you know so for me i'm
like not injured in the first day
many brands out the gate it's like power
like that so
this is again not pandering we well the
story that doesn't get told enough was
we
actually had a column on good magazine
so this is where i mean the alliances
that's why i
like networking and stuff mm-hmm this
guy tim fernand was the editor
now he's at quartz if you guys know
quartz so quartz
is like this tech kind of like hip
uh online magazine tim fernell's i don't
think
if he's watching tim like shout outs to
you he knew i was a writer i
both my co-founder and i also wrote and
did publishing in journalism when we
were in
college undergrad and so
he and i had like blogs that people read
he actually had a huge
following he had a hundred thousand
dollar 100 000 person tumblr
um called you might find yourself which
is why his handle is ymfy
like my co-founder ben so tim had read
our writing and said what if you
chronicled
your idea from the very beginning on so
those articles are still online right
now
the magazine was called good magazine
the founder of that was the
was the son or the heir of ink magazine
inc magazine
so it's his son who wanted this like do
good do-gooder magazine that was about
social responsibility
so he we used us as a column so for like
20 straight weeks
i wrote so we launched in week 15 of the
columns
so i think maybe had eight weeks or
something like that so you built your
following before the launch
people were falling in love with your
process it reminds me of this book
called show your work
have you heard of that i've heard of it
yeah yeah and basically it's it's this
concept
of you know tell people your process and
it's kind of like how we're doing right
now you know with the fans that are
watching someone out there might
create or follow and you know do
something based off of that yeah
i mean i watch you you guys show your
work all the time i remember when you
guys were building out
um you know like jk party
or um because i was just a viewer at
that time
and then ad as you guys built your
businesses i'd be like oh you know the
jk guys
they built the barbell begrade they
built this they got the time sip matcha
yeah and then i had known june one of
your partners and that's when i was like
wow like but they have a platform that
had an audience that they told their
story
that's why i think the storytelling is
what i think
if especially if you're i'm not good at
a lot of things but the one thing that
people
don't really i think they underestimate
is the power of story
in business people say oh that's
youtubers i'm like no no no no
that's branding bro yeah because that's
marketing exactly what is advertisement
it's telling a story of how we're gonna
solve your problem your life's problems
exactly right but that's crazy how
people don't think of it that way yeah
people are like oh you did it because
you have great design you did it because
you
you cater to white people or hipsters
i'm like dude no it's a story
like i mean i'm gonna say this in the
early three days first it's gonna taste
good too
yeah your product has to be good
hopefully but you know people
for the first three five years we got so
much [ __ ] i know you guys could relate
to this it's for like
they didn't understand the full story
you know especially the way media works
right they're like oh this is a snippet
you as an entrepreneur know exactly what
you want to do what barbell
brigade with jundy matcha you know but
people always
especially like not they're not even
haters they're just people who just
critics are into the status quo that's
how i would say yeah they're critics
yeah they just are like they don't like
change they're like oh they're purists
sometimes
and they're like oh well oh you're here
fixing boba i'm like i'm not here fixing
but what i'm doing is i'm trying to grow
the pie yeah and so but i'm a
businessman so i always
you know in in kind of business
philosophy it's calling
like growing the market expanding the
market so
you know when another boba shop opens
generally they steal from just other
boba shops
when bubba guys opens we are taking
people from
jonah juice or i call brone juice i love
them but brone juice
or um uh starbucks phil's coffee yeah
that's actually where
a lot of our crowd comes from yeah how
do you know well our employee base
i almost never hire from boba shops like
i didn't even apply
i get my people from x starbucks x ice
cream
salt and straws and am i about to say
brands yeah so yeah
kim songstraw the sponsor sponsored that
so that's how
we we we kind of the
team member base that we call and our
outside crowd
started becoming the same and that's why
i'd never
be honest people like does that ever get
to you i'm like no if you're a decent
entrepreneur and you have a very strong
vision
if you know what you're doing is
authentic to you there's nobody who can
question that because people would be
like oh that's not real asian
and i would be like i'm asian american
first of all that's all to think to
asian american you're telling me that
there's
i i'm in america you're telling me i
need to have boba exactly the same way
as taiwan and i'm taiwanese
no [ __ ] way that's like that's that's
now we say what's racist that's
a microaggression from you and you of
your own people yeah like that's that's
like you
limiting yourself right that's
self-hating what if you made the boba
like red white and blue
yeah with guns on it yeah so
um we have some questions from our fans
that
uh you know i think they know who you
are
but our first one is from deep effin
value
and he asked how much has getting an mba
helped you with your work
and do you believe it's essential oh
that's a good question yeah
i think there's the reddit string the
[ __ ] value isn't that that's the
gamestop guy yeah yeah
but i don't think it's really him no no
no uh cool
i would say you know here's what i would
say
i'm not here to [ __ ] on my my old
colleagues in my old world but
i don't know if you guys feel you guys
had decent education right so
not in business no i majored in
psychology but i think college was
important for me because i was a dumb
ass
see i i was i was a dumb i was i'm like
uh like a like a like a
generally i'm just like uh i need a
discipline
like i think i'm i don't know maybe
we're all entrepreneurs so
i i tend to be like rebellious right
yeah so i feel like college or any that
type of institution
hone like makes you disciplined makes
you get up on cla in class at the same
time
makes you like not be crazy around
your classmates like it kind of brings
you in so very few things
like in business school it's just
another kind of tier in grad school
you're generally if you go to a good one
i went to i went to haas berkeley
so you generally are quote-unquote like
cream of the crop that's how you get in
so at that point i still thought people
are like oh you're a ceo of a
of a you know eight plus figure dollar
company and i'm like
yeah but he's like oh you don't you
don't look like one i was like well what
are you doing
i know what exactly i was like do you
think all ceos wear certain ties or they
don't there's nine figure guys that look
like bums
[ __ ] dude yeah exactly every zero you
just look worse right the ceo of hot dog
on a stick looks nuts
i can pull the picture out of the circus
[Laughter]
i want to see what their all hands look
like yeah um they have a big
mascot coming out so i think
in the nba then is kind of like you can
have things
that replicate an mba but i think this
organization the system and maybe
formalized networks where sometimes i do
a call and i
i just say hey i'm like a berkeley host
alum
they'll actually take your call like it
opens doors yeah
because of the clicks because yeah
exactly because of alumni
so i think i think there's a little bit
of that but then you could technically
get that
through like the school of hard knocks
you could just be coming out of another
network or kind of like crew
like you know you have these clicks and
whether in culture and media and fashion
like
that you could have came out of that an
exact same for mbas two years
and gotten very similar results i
personally think
the mb had nothing to do with kind of
too much the success of early day bubba
guys
i would say now yeah it's pretty handy
like my old spreadsheet work my ability
to
you know were we don't franchise and not
that you know it's bad or anything
but we we have a franchise and we
haven't raced series a yet and that's
what i want to
also dispel people like oh you must
franchise and i'm like no we got to 20
stories self
self-funded yeah wow so we're looking at
maybe series a
but the nba helps there because when you
do that and you're talking to the guys
who funded
the first starbucks or these things
they're like
andrew we can make you the next blue
bottle well real quick series a
is the funding from the bank funding
from institutional
it could be banks family family funds
fail the people that don't know
what are the different ones we have
angel and then yeah oh yeah this is
oh i never get to talk about it because
we're i mean in the room we know but you
know like i love this
yeah usually people don't ask these like
business nerdy questions i think
so high level it's how you get money
right so if you're if you're listening
you get money differently it's called
capital many cases right like seed
capital startup capital
and then there's different phases of a
company so usually you're beginning
first set of checks is called seed money
sometimes angel money
and so that's like in food business you
know usually it's like five figures
six figures right to start your first
restaurant in something if it's like a
tech startup it's like
you know a million or more and so
when you do that you usually figure out
where you're getting your pool from so
think about the check size right so if
you're getting five figure checks it
could be just
family friends and all that kind of rich
uncle rich on goal right that's how it
starts twenty five thousand dollars
start my restaurant
if you're starting a tech company a rich
uncle usually is gonna have to cut like
five hundred thousand dollars
to do a tech company so or whatever
anything in between
so series a is usually um so we have
seed angel
early stage and then there's series a
usually is right when you kind of are
you have your idea locked
and you really want to start kind of
like making it like
have market viability so you know
food series a is usually like it's
definitely seven figures or more so it's
usually like
five mil ten mil then there's something
called expansion capital and that's when
you get more mature
that's sometimes venture capital so
venture capital is any early stage
venture meaning from seed money all the
way to
like early stage is venture money so you
can have
angels under venture capital as well i'm
a venture angel i people know that i
also invest in other companies so
check sizes i cut are like five figures
on early day food concepts or tech
companies
so that's like 10 to 90 000 yeah exactly
that's exactly
so i like to cut 25 to 50 000 checks so
um i only say this not to like it's
people never know this is not an
internet
and i want people to understand how this
whole ecosystem works well a lot of
people that don't understand
entrepreneur talk they hear this and
they go oh you just throw money at
people
like it's it's really a different
language and
how you deal with cash in like um
like it's work like it like it really is
the take money to make money kind of
system and a lot of this
can just disappear yeah it's more viewed
as like tokens in the game rather than
like money to buy
the things you want to buy but most of
this we don't expect it to come back
when we cut these checks no
we don't i mean you guys are i mean you
guys invested in other places okay like
some businesses fail some don't and or
some
some you're gonna get pennies on the
dollar back but then you do enough of
them like a portfolio
you kind of end up with a larger kind of
larger portfolio return so i guess the
the question of series a is usually when
you
getting ready to expand once you hit
expansion capital like really
scaling that's like 10 million plus for
food businesses
uh tech companies use like 100 mil
that's like really the blowout
like these like um billion dollar
evaluations yeah
that's usually what you call um like
late stage like
series b c d f all the way through
or private equity but private equity is
another type of money where it's usually
it's a bunch of rich people's money
really and they're just trying to hold
the value
so private equity it's funny because all
of this sounds
like rich people money yeah right
from five figures and above it even
within rich people
though like how we know rich it's
completely
huge the difference because you have old
money air money you have these funds
that has been existing for like 100
years or whatever
and they just have this diverse
portfolio that they've
they have money managers that just
throws money everywhere and it's [ __ ]
crazy
it's not every time you add a zero it's
a new world that's what yeah that's true
it's like your problems just become
different that's why i'm looking at this
right here yeah i'm like oh when i first
came in i was like are these real like
you guys really
um uh food
there is tied up on the internet very
tied up
and there's only about you could count
the zeros in your hand
well also like well that's the other
thing too like i don't think people
realize how much money is illiquid
right it's not i can take it out of my
bank account illiquid
so more like evaluation
yeah it's all paper yeah that's what
they don't realize when they're talking
about billionaires usually they think a
billionaire can cut a check for a
billion dollars but that's really not
how
that [ __ ] works he probably has like 20
in his bank account
and in order to people like well why
don't you just sell some stock a lot of
times especially if you're the founder
ceo
selling stock is like a huge ordeal like
for me
i if i take series a i mean there's
already these these
i almost went through a process one time
actually almost i'd actually signed a
term sheet which i don't think people
know
but uh long story short the last week
before the money was about to get wired
this is like
four or five years ago uh we had a
falling out
so it's a little bit dramatic and then
um that's why i've been so against
vc money until even now because ever
since that i didn't like what you call
like
people think they own you you have to
have a little piece yeah so
the the in these kind of contracts
they'll be like well
how do you sell because sometimes
selling your own shares of if you're a
founder or ceo
it's the signal right that's why elon
can't like just unload all those tesla
stocks well didn't um bezos do that and
drop his own
price yeah yeah well he did it and then
every he bought back because it was like
i got it cheap
you got it well yeah or buffett
everything he buys everyone knows about
and tries to copy by him
it's [ __ ] hilarious yeah so um we
have another question
so how do you attract and maintain
customers in a saturated market for boba
and
tea and i want to know this one too
because i'm like hmm
did you ask that question no no no it's
by jkjk
yeah um
everything what most things that we buy
or sell like they're all commodities
right
so commodities are anything that's
traded with intrinsic value not
augmented value meaning uh gold water
drinks or technically commodity anybody
can make it
the augmented value of something that's
i'm doing marketing speak because i used
to be a marketing guy
augmented value is when you put value on
top of your intrinsic value meaning
as a marketer my job was to make status
exclusivity
special a feeling those are way you
attach value on something
intrinsic coffee and starbucks yeah
i mean that wasn't like that type of
coffee wasn't ever made before
it was like it was never had the value
that the their coffee
it sucks it's but people love the image
and they love the logo and they like
going into it and smelling it and being
around all of it and it's the experience
that's part of what you're paying for
right because
you can start a coffee shop but they
have maybe an extra 500 square feet
so you people can sit around that 500
square feet of sitting
in the cafe of the second home that
starbucks calls it the second place
that is value they invested because they
didn't they built a store that's not
1500 square feet they built a store
that's 2 000 square feet
that 500 times four dollars square foot
to 2
000 a month extra to just have a space
gets monetized in some brand experience
way right
that's why boba guy stores where our
stores are bigger than almost every boba
shops we have
1600 square foot stores and it's because
that's more before the pendant
way bigger than these guys stores way
bigger way way bigger way way
bigger good for you although our
princeton location is quite big so
we're getting there we're getting there
i'm going to sell my junebe shares if
anybody wants to buy it
actually i'll snatch that i'll take it
yeah i'm going to
go buy some bubbles
[Music]
[Laughter]
so your goal is to decommodetize i don't
get too far into it so two
so basically to summarize like okay how
do you stand out
attract maintain customers in a
saturated market
so storage how do you stand out deco
monetize
the textbook definition of decommodizing
things are adding augmented value
to great differentiation so um tell
stories that's different
uh getting access to things that they
don't have access to and adding value to
that access
so it could be a product that's i'm
bulba guys is famous for strawberry
matcha lattes or
dirty horchatas or korean banana milk
you can only get that there
then you create a moat around so people
don't know we control a lot of our own
ip we just don't
throw lawsuits at people but we own the
term boba bay
because we kind of started that right i
know people make boba bay shirts
but you know i can't send cease and
desist everywhere because they're going
to say that andrew and ben are bullies
but i guess i'm smart if i see a big guy
use it i don't care if a small guy
like nike ended up using it yeah yeah
then i'm going to just drop a huge
lawsuit on yeah a little tip to the
small guys right now bubba basically
but if you guys watch we watch sorry i
might still send it to you and it's not
going to be worth your while
but the idea is like you need to kind of
create that differentiation
so again you guys do pretty i mean you
guys do really well for small businesses
because
like i see your story telling i mean we
were talking about your mushroom thing i
was just like damn
you got me hooked on that all christmas
i think thanks man
you bought like 10 for your team i don't
know and this guy didn't give me a
discount
i found out later that he had one i
would i didn't know you were going to
buy 10.
but going kind of kind of adding to that
so daydream asks is it easy to start a
business considering that a lot of
youtubers have their own businesses what
do you actually need to start one
what depends what kind of business yeah
uh i think in general
this person might be talking about yeah
starting a business in general
i'm thinking from you know a person
who's never started a business right it
seems so
difficult because like like the question
before that it seems
everything seems already done everything
seems
already saturated and also if you
compare yourself to like people like us
we have an audience we have other brands
like
how do you even compete it feels like a
you know
task that you just can't climb over oh
yeah and i think that's that's the ques
that's what i'm reading that this
question is probably how do you need to
actually start one
do you guys play like uh like you guys
play gamers you guys
no play games you're sure i played games
he plays games i haven't played a long
time uh
madden yeah man was my [ __ ] so i think i
think
people in founding teams have like power
scores like madden like you know like
patrick mahomes like he's like a 98 and
and speed or
you know agility or whatever the
different overall
ovr ovr yeah so i don't play much
um i think you know
i think it's very similar like i'm a big
call of duty person right so
you have a certain kit that everyone's
built with right so
like oh this one this is my sniper kit
this is my like run and gun kit
so whether it's a matter or whatever you
have certain scores that you can kind of
max out on
i think if you're an influencer yeah you
start on an awareness score
a little higher it just boom you just
start with it but operation score
yeah education everything
but i think that's ultimately it okay
because you should like like use your
strengths find what your strengths are
and then you can play to those strengths
yeah because i think you guys are
selling yourself short because i think
you guys are good operators honestly
i know because i've seen your i've been
through you don't know the truth it's
not because of them though
yeah we partner with great operators
yeah actually shout out to all that i
know
i know your team he's watching they're
in kind of like you know without kind of
a certain hype or awareness notoriety or
whatever
you don't get people in the door so it's
kind of like this funnel and this
yes cycle so everybody has their part so
i guess if you don't have full awareness
it you got to remember most people don't
have your guys's clout
so instead of them comparing it to jk
and and everybody else who came out of
youtube and started something
i would just compare it like look at all
the other success stories we didn't come
truly with a youtube following and stuff
we're reverse
we actually now most people know we
invested in media we went the other way
we're taking our money and we're
actually going back into producing
things
for like you know we we do stuff with
vice and then uh complex right we did
hot ones last year or two years ago
so i think what everybody has to start
somewhere
we chose kind of a branded route which
happened in
my wheelhouse but i didn't have the
awareness route i didn't have like the
megaphone
i don't think i was a great operator so
i don't even think i was winning in
operations
so and then i got better in operations
and then now finally maybe i'm starting
to get a megaphone
so everybody kind of branches off
differently
but don't be disheartened i think the
majority of successful entrepreneurs are
sitting out there they're probably if
they're even
listening watching it's that same
mentality that is going to grow because
i
i don't know if you guys are like this i
know we talk we feel this way
you're always learning you're always one
to be like how did you do that
that mentality is usually indicative of
someone who
has the right kind of like mindset for
entrepreneurship now they also have to
be good at
action so if you're watching these and
you happen to be very action oriented
then i think that's a really good combo
for entrepreneurship
cool well thanks a lot andrew um stay
tuned because we're going to continue
this
again but that's all we have time for
today guys
what an outro
[Music]
you